we are happy to say hello to Chris
Fowler now Chris how you doing thanks
for being with us grape all excited
about this weekend and happy to join you
how you doing I'm doing very well
looking forward to talking about the
Buckeyes the Wolverines here coming up
here but let's start with what I know
you watched last night the brand new
college football playoff rankings let's
start with the view from 10,000 feet
your number one reaction what intrigued
you the most about what you saw last
night and not a lot because I didn't
expect I didn't expect a ton of movement
I mean we've had these weeks where you
know there's seismic shifts and where
you know three of the top four lose and
yet we have to try to predict how the
committee is going to react and you have
weeks where there's not not a lot of
movement and I think that you know that
this has not been one of the more
difficult years to figure out what you
agree I mean at least not so far I think
a few more things happen and I said
along I said the decisions at the end of
the season might be as difficult as any
they had to make if you're dealing with
a two-loss Big Ten Champion if you're
dealing with your to Los teams for the
first time really being in that bracket
which hasn't happened yet if you're
dealing with a one-loss potentially
pac-12 champion Washington it's on the
outside looking in that would cause a
lot of concern for any anybody in that
entire conference so I still think
there's some difficult choices ahead but
i think this week was one of the ones
where it wasn't it wasn't as difficult
chris's we were on that committee and
you had a vote what would be your number
one criteria resume how you're playing
right now one loss record what would it
be it wouldn't be the last to how you're
playing right now is an important thing
you factor in but it wouldn't be the
first thing you look at Paul because
this is still a regular season that
means something what happens in
september-october your main mean less
when you evaluate a team at the end but
it's not insignificant and I think that
you know the four best teams is a very
simple mandate now how you arrived at
that is different but I think that
though the football guys on there tend
to think who you know who would you not
want to play at the moment and I think
that that has some value but you have to
factor in a resume don't you because you
have to look at metrics
you have to put that into the equation
otherwise we would render the first part
of the season meaningless I when people
say USC belongs in the playoffs they're
certainly in the camp that believes that
you know right now with Sam garlic
quarterback with the with the defense
coming together that's a nasty team to
try to face and while I agree with that
I still have a problem you know with
just rolling off three losses if they
have I mean that I never imagined that
we'd be talking about a 3 loss team
right in a 4 playoff bracket that if you
expand to eight you're talking about
teams that have two three losses most
years and that's why a lot of people
don't like the idea of expanding right
most probably do but those who don't
feel like well here we don't want to
have teams in the playoff it that have
taken three losses and yeah us seats a
gun a tough challenge they played the
ultimate opponent in Alabama early and
that certainly needs to be considered
but it wasn't a competitive game i call
that game and as much as they've
improved i have a little bit of a hard
time saying that that's one of the four
you know most deserving or best teams
right now yeah i don't know what stands
out more Krista fact that they do have
those three losses or that one loss felt
that bad in everybody's sonn Paul
Burmeister talking to Chris Fowler Chris
will be on the call with Kirk Herbstreit
on Saturday Michigan and Ohio State no
change in the town for Chris Alabama
Ohio state-michigan Clemson but you look
at five through ten Washington Wisconsin
penn state Oklahoma Colorado year old
school and oklahoma state which of those
schools five through ten do you look at
and think has the best chance of finding
its way in it's actually surreal to
think about colorado in that group I
don't know any people understand i'll
get back to your question but as an alum
of that school who was there when they
were the worst program in the world then
got to cover them winning a championship
a few years later then watch them sink
back in and struggle and their first
five years in the pac-12 to see them in
the top ten Paul I can't even explain
what that's like it's incredible I mean
they're an excellent team and and you
know they go ahead and take care of Utah
they're very very deserving team to be
in the pac-12 championship I just can't
wrap my head around them yeah I think
that you know we covered Oklahoma last
week the Oklahoma is an interesting team
because they did
on overall probably the most challenging
non-conference schedule and Ohio State
Houston loss to both of them were
sitting there one and two and written
off at that point and I get that but you
know the way they're playing now
defensive they still on a great
defensive team by any stretch
offensively they're among the best if
not if not the hardest to stop often in
the country right now and I think that
you know they just have one game last
home game Oklahoma State next weekend a
chance to put a quality one on there and
then and then wait for the Big Ten to
shake out yeah the weird thing is you
had four Big Ten teams kind of log jam
ahead of teams like Oklahoma and the
others and I think that you know it's
going to be fascinating to see how that
plays out Penn State Michigan State not
an automatic win but Alliance this week
I mean they're favored for a reason it's
weird because it's the second straight
year Michigan Ohio State play then they
have to wait and see about for a game
that begins about when that game
finishes what's going to happen in the
case of last year they needed Michigan
say to lose that's right but now they
need Penn State to lose to Michigan
State and they won't even know if
they're going to win the division or not
right that's Ohio state-michigan
obviously would take care of it by
winning the game but but those teams are
going to play each other whatever
happens in penn state win the division
you know they're going to cry with
wisconsin one's going to be out and the
winner is going to be sitting there were
two losses and i think the overall
strength the Big Ten would probably put
a two-loss Big Ten team into the
playoffs over Oklahoma and that's where
that's where the big argument would be I
think because of the big club gets
kicked around a lot the Big Ten is
perceived to be the strongest conference
at the top do you think that's true
autumn did do you think that's the case
and I look at it through the lens of a
former big send student athlete in
quarterback but for so many years I was
defending the Big Ten they were thought
to be third fourth fifth best major
conference they're ranked 23 6 and 7 is
is this the best conference in college
football right now the way you see it
sec fans would laugh at that notion i
think you know i think the the boring
but sensible answer is wait and see
because i'm dying to see how it plays
out in the bowls and in a playoff you
know but you look at a team like Penn
State um you know again tremenda
his job recovery they were they were on
the ropes just about out against ohio
state and who knows what direction
they're season would have gone if they
had found a way through special teams
and and pass rush to get back and win
that game they've been a different team
since they're one of those teams you
have to sort of overlook that they did
lose a game to pittsburgh was a you know
we've seen this ass clemson it's a
pretty good team they lost a couple of
plays in throws into the end zone had a
chance to win it at the end so no
disgrace in losing that game but i don't
know if they're the seventh the best
eighth best team in the country right
yeah it's a and I think that big ten at
the top has has 22 excellent teams in
Michigan Ohio state-wisconsin has proven
itself and they're trying to play
short-handed and obviously whenever LSU
is enormous yeah it's hard to it's hard
to argue they deserve to be able to flex
I mean the big ten's been kicked around
and laughed at in the years by some of
the other top leagues and this is the
year for them to flex but well it's a
big call to said I get for the top eight
don't you think I think so too i would
like to look at it and call the big ten
the best conference I just don't know if
you lined up one through the bottom
they're having an outstanding year I'm
proud of them but I don't know if
they're better than the SEC Chris I have
a bunch that's how you should judge I
agree with that I think that's why I
said top not top to bottom because i
think that the SEC still has good depth
i just i think the middle of the SEC is
softer than we've usually seen and
there's just no it's deemed to be
alabama and the rest and we'll see how
much of a fight in auburn can put up in
that game but boy I mean it's there's no
doubt it's indisputable that it's a down
year for the SEC there's no debating
that it's just whether or not the
overall depth of the league is still is
still at the top most important question
the most significant one most
significant one here Chris for the last
better Big Ten quarterback in the 90s
Kirk Herbstreit or me hahaha it is funny
man do I go with the the correct answer
or the guy have to work with every week
I don't know I don't know if there you
go enough said I think we should stop
right there I appreciate that responds
very well done Chris thank you well hey
well good luck
good luck sit next to her be four three
or four hours on Saturday it's going to
be intense it's going to be a way to do
game day for many years it is my first
game calling Ohio state-michigan but I'd
obviously did game day a lot of times
when we were there and sitting sitting
between Kirk and Desmond it's a little
bit of a crackling tension I'm telling
you to real yes very very real and I'm
looking forward to getting inside the
stadium and sort of feeling that tension
on a huge scale because i've i've been
in the ballpark for a couple of ohio
state machine games where it's just been
incredibly tense is it different to
bidding to be a fan of those soup yeah I
think it is yeah I think I think it
couldn't he could not be different I
mean it was a captain he played and he's
very unbiased when he does his call sure
but I think you could feel the energy
you know maybe maybe Colorado make the
rose bowl and I'll call the rose bowl
and we'll get a chance to experience
that's like yeah but i think i think
that you know that's one of the features
of this game is that is that it's it's a
very modern landscape with the playoffs
in play but it goes back to the early
early days of the sport and that's
what's timeless about it and and that is
you know how desperately hungry michigan
is to break through and how absolutely
determined to house say it is to not let
them do that and to keep their thumb on
michigan it's one of the most one-sided
areas in this rivalry something that
surprises people who around the outside
and don't realize how dominant ohio
state's been but right but I you can
just feel it from Michigan said this is
with all those seniors call all those
guys that that you saw when they played
Iowa who were disappointed in themselves
this is a chance of redemption not only
for that game but for the last few years
and you can really feel it when you talk
to those guys they got to spend some
time with you and I was City before that
game and obviously they lost to the
Hawkeyes they struggled last week
against Indiana what's what's gone
missing from Michigan the last couple of
weeks that was so much there the first
part of the season the dynamic offensive
a I think the game we saw in Iowa you
know they just missed the downfield
shots that they were making and as you
know as well as anyone you know when you
have that style of an offense and you're
going to be going to grind away the
success rate in the downfield shots
which would state
healthy and throwing the beautiful deep
balls was really high right I mean that
that makes a difference guys I think
when you watch michigan play it you know
not every play but the overall
philosophy is a lot like what you see on
sundays and it's hard to win on Sunday
if you don't hit those downfield shots
when they're there they didn't in that
game the offensive line did not look
like it had against a lot of people I
was I think they would have a right to
be disappointed in their line play on
both sides and then it was a very very
constricted performance against against
Indiana I mean some tough elements at
the end of that game weren't trying to
work his way in and play but the offense
was was stagnant stale not very dynamic
that's good that's going to all have to
change in a big way yep don't you think
it's important which coach is going to
call a bowl game you're going to try to
grind away and play single wing football
if you're out of state or or you know
hand the ball off and pawn if your
Michigan play field position all that
stuff and that's going to be tough to
move the ball on either defense I think
I think whichever offensive staff frees
itself up take some risks and connect
when they have the chances for those for
those chunk plays right um goes a long
way to win but I'm really intrigued to
see how the game is called Chris you're
going to be at the center of it all you
got a great seat look forward to hearing
your call but enjoy Michigan and Ohio
State happy thanksgiving and thanks for
spending time with us baby you Paul have
a great holiday and enjoyed it the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience